faire de la tyrolienne sur la tour
eiffel 115 mètres du sol
un survol du champ de mars une folie ce
n'est pas la première fois que la tour
eiffel se transforme en terrain de jeux
de mémoire de tour eiffel
il n'y a pas de précédent et paris qui
ne s'étonnent pas facile mais on avait
quand même j'avais jusque là 1945
des alpinistes confondent mont blanc est
tour eiffel et à la veille de noël trois
alpinistes encore des hauts risques et
l'ascension la plus extraordinaire est
la plus imprévues début des années 50
c'est rose gold surnommé l'impératrice
du trapèze qui volent aux côtés de la
dame de fer
maintenant attention aux gold a joué
avec la mort ses exploits étaient tous
encadrés mais rapidement certains
casques ou comprennent le potentiel de
la tour eiffel
combiné à un sport extrême le coup de
com est assuré comme en 1977 il faut
tout vous dire c'est pour la publicité
d'un film qui sort actuellement sur les
écrans de cloche dans la neige avec
christian marin que l'autre vedette
sportive du film alain pachoud s'est
jetée ou plutôt s'est lancé comme vous
le voyez avec un deltaplane depuis le
premier étage seulement de la tour
eiffel les exploits s'enchaînent
l'antenne la tour eiffel en vélo en moto
à présent premier record sur la tour en
1891 l'ascension jusqu'au premier étage
en échasses voici le dernier en date la
sanction jusqu'au deuxième niveau en
moto le but battre des records ou faire
la promo d'une marque mais pour certains
c'est juste un défi personnel
un néo-zélandais de 29 ans alan john
hackett s'est jeté dans le vide là
peut-être la première retenue simplement
par une longue corde élastique accroché
un pied sans autorisation le risque
c'est de voir arriver la police juste
après l'exploit
c'est pas mal mais un peu inconscient et
pourquoi nous prenons les autorisations
pour faire ça
[Musique]